[Applause]
[Music]
if you refuse to leave you're going to
go to jail for trespassing you can't you
want to read this these are my i'm not
going to actually do my federal rights
grab your stuff let's go
no i'm not going okay you're in
violation of the law
you want to hear this or not
ma'am
what are you doing don't worry don't
jerk away from me listen to me don't
jerk away can you see this
yeah i saw it yeah
you see this you know where it came from
turn around do you know where it came
from man turn around okay i hope
everyone's filming this because this is
a major violation listen i don't want to
hurt you a major violation
ladies give me your arm
you're going to take me down yeah
oh well that's great
okay should we want to leave oh you guys
are in such trouble oh my gosh yes i'm
sorry that's my personal business you
may not have it
that is my personal business you may not
have it you are taking my rights away
yeah that's what happened
you know what that cup is really really
tight whatever is when you remove
you pull away from off no i'm trying to
fool you people i'm trying to school you
people am i right
there
[Music]
hey buddy
see ya
terry right oh you were later the other
day causing issues from galveston
no i was a lady the other day
[Applause]
you didn't learn your listening
galveston
what are you doing taking your bag off
oh wow lady that's my business it's
officer barkley
is this uh
[Applause]
have a seat
have a fee
they got a warrant for her
[Applause]
have a seat
this is getting fun
where's my phone please
have a feet where's my phone sir
go ahead
[Applause]
you have an id in here
uh
actually i think it's my license is in
my pickups okay go ahead put your leg in
all right there's not enough room man
[Applause]
there's not enough room man
listen
i'm asking you nicely to put your leg in
if not i'm going to drag you in
now
[Applause]
you're going to wash it
[Applause]
but i actually leave twice and i told
her she was here to me she's going to go
to jail
[Applause]
[Applause]
there you
i go say i had to have an id to be here
no we need that you need to give it you
say
okay this is the call taker able to get
a
last name she's refusing to identify
yourself it's my god-given right to be
here on this planet and you cannot tell
me otherwise correct you just lied to me
i lied about what you said i had to have
an id to be here no you got to identify
yourself when you're legally detained
you can play back on your video when
you're legally detained you have a duty
to identify yourself to a police officer
okay so they're saying when i'm
legally detained which i was not that i
have can you try to run her without a
date of birth
white female approximately 45 years of
age
[Music]
because right now
as a call taker i know you want to have
them on there for your safety purposes
yes but right now you and i need to be
talking not them says who
you need to continue having a
conversation with me
so you said that she shoved you she want
to file assault charges she's saying you
shoved her and she has witnesses you
have witnesses to say that she shoved
you she has the manager no no okay there
are other employees that were in the
fitting i would hope okay other
employees well there's also another
woman without a mask
isn't that interesting how she only
picked me well i have nothing to do with
that
the white person not the black person
wearing a mask do you think it's a
racist thing i don't know we're not here
to talk about race well you know what it
kind of seems like it's a racist thing
when the black woman doesn't have a mask
on but she comes after the white one
that's i mean that's the only thing
that's the only way to file a complaint
with nordstrom okay but as soon as i'll
complete with you for her assaulting me
okay and she also wants to file assault
charges against you okay so the valley's
good
hopefully they have cameras at nordstrom
to prove all this
do you have a middle name
do you have another name yeah my name is
jesus
really from that the negative
white female protein
why is that your business because we
have to identify if i can't identify you
i'm taking you to jail
okay this is getting here now there's
students they can't identify me they're
taking you to jail how do you identify
the homeless
they tell us their names their date of
birth we have we
i mean it's
they
work with us
here anything your reverse checks
well we can't get to that we can't get
to that point we're not on either side
we don't know what's going on because we
can't identify
but we can't even get any information
from you okay this happened at nordstrom
rack man what are you saying you can't
leave because right now you're still
detained
oh my gosh
no you can't you are being detained
why am i being today because we don't
know who you are okay i'm being
detangled
figure out what's going on if you're a
victim of assault you need we need to
know who you are
how did you know my name was carabelle
because i heard you say it you said it
on the phone when you called 9-1-1
don't lie no you are lying to me i just
heard you call the police officer that i
talked to and get my name now you're
like a police officer on the phone now
you're not in the fitting room you are
lying stop this is the second time i
caught you in a lie okay replay your
video i'm not lying okay okay
is the situation worse no you are
by not following the law first of all i
don't have to identify myself you do
actually i don't it's called common law
you should read up on it i do not
okay so we both know that i don't i am a
woman of god this is my right as much as
it is yours this is my land as much as
it is yours i did not
sign up for this i am a christian woman
of god and you are not going to put your
disgusting rules on me that are false
and not true i will not have it you
understand that
i will not have it i'm sick of being
bullied i'm sick of being lied to and
it's not going to happen anymore do you
understand
the cdc just released turn around oh my
gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh
[Music]
they're your parents
oh your answer is your aunt on your way
back flash is coming back
[Music]
cool do me a favor take a deep breath
and blow
[Music]
all right do me a favor try one more
time
deep breath don't put it don't go too so
far
[Music]
in is there a certain problem mind your
business
[Music]
all right where's your hand at you have
a phone number
how old are you
[Music]
all right take a deep breath keep
blowing
[Music]
keep going
[Music]
all right
yo guys even is your aunt she is of
[Music]
age all right let's go grab her real
quick we're gonna have them pour that
all out
[Music]
[Music]
that's
[Music]
[Music]
in the beach
[Music]
[Music]
disrespect you i didn't do anything to
get written up did i pull the sheet now
your call's in the scene you want it
all right i'll give you one more chance
to give me your last name just be quiet
i didn't disrespect you okay and you're
and i you don't need to write my name
that's like you wasted your time coming
over here you could wait here for her
okay what's your last name
okay that's it i'm done with you do you
have coughs on you no matt
get over here talk to me don't touch me
you're about to get dropped
[Applause]
what are you doing 5043 send me another
unit
in the beach we have one resistance
get off of me what are you
back up
you're not allowed to hit me and choke
me like that
grab it chelsea
you're just gonna let me
[Music]
i wasn't drinking anything just smell it
open bro
yeah
i can't believe you did that
get off of me
[Music]
people
yeah well yeah i didn't arrest you
he said that he'd had to tell this guy
multiple times to get off him
jumping bumping into him on tyler yeah
our security yeah kept bumping into him
excuse me
you don't need to touch me put your hand
on your head put your hand up on your
head because you're under arrest
push your hand no explain to me why
you're arresting me what did i do i
don't want to throw you on the ground
what did i do please don't do this okay
i'll put my hand behind my hand your
hand up on your head right now hey what
the fuck did i do ma'am what did i do
what the fuck are you doing
stay down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
please
i'm not resisting jesus
[Music]
oh my god
are you fucking kidding me
i did not do anything wrong
i didn't do anything wrong
please help me
please
please you're hurting me
you're hurting me
i'm not even can you stand up please can
you let go of me
you're under arrest okay i'm not gonna
rest for any reason stand up please oh
let me go
let me go
let me go and i will stand up get your
arm off me and i will stand up record me
bitch
fucking let go of me and i'll stand up
329 bring your car here please are you
fucking kenny i can feel you shaking you
little pussy fuck you
are you kidding me
are you fucking kidding me
i didn't do anything wrong please please
please call me you're a girl people no
ma'am i'll pull down your dress for you
anything wrong
[Music]
she's in custody i haven't gone through
her
296 276 so you code
[Applause]
i four do anything wrong
ma'am do you need paramedics at all fuck
you
who's paramedics but not from him
because fuck it
oh yeah
[Laughter]
can you please have medical aid respond
to linen and walnut
are in
custody requesting to be checked out
after a use of force